well
[Applause]
it is thrifty week on our show here and
we love a theme and winning money is fun
saving money is also incredibly
important and very gratifying it can
also be very creative
we challenged our good friend celebrity
designer mikael welch who is a drew crew
member and sustainable stylist sarah
tarasinski
and
they did a little upcycling challenge
now upcycling is all the rage i think we
used to call it vintage shopping and now
we're calling it upcycling because we
see the value
in buying older things not only are they
more affordable but they can be better
for our environment so we sent them to
an incredible thrift store here in new
york to put their skills to the test
i love this video take a look
hey drew we are here outside of city
opera thrift shop this shop is amazing
they have been giving to the opera
community here in new york city for well
over 40 years inside they have
everything from clothes decor you name
it i've got my friend right here sarah t
and she is a sustainable stylist and
we're gonna go head-to-head and pick
items that we're going to up cycle
that's right are you ready i'm not ready
this is a serious challenge girl was
born ready this is all i do one
two
two and a half you cheated three
[Music]
think again sister
that's a pretty cool lamp i'm definitely
into lamp up cycles because there's so
many things you can do with these
especially older ones i like it but it
just seems basic i've made all sorts of
storage with books before
i love taking beautiful pieces and
incorporating them into an upcycle i
need more fabric but this would be a
beautiful ottoman sarah don't be over
here peeking at my stuff you stay back
there right back at you mikael i need to
find a jacket that i can reupholster a
ottoman with
i mean this has nothing to do with the
challenge i'm sorry drew i just really
want to throw this on because i think it
might be a good fit
[Music]
i was digging this one it's a little
more like masculine and toned we have
like straps here where the straps fed
into here where it's almost like a
handle per se i found this beautiful
lamp and i'm so excited to upcycle it so
i'm ready to check out gonna head
upstairs i am ready to check out my
friend all right thank you so much
so how do you feel oh i feel amazing how
do you feel i'm just telling you now
i've got it in the bag and yours needs
to go in a trash bag mine will come out
of the trash and look amazing when i'm
done because that's what i do well we're
gonna let drew make the final decision
so drew we'll see you back at the studio
i cannot wait to weigh in because
sarah are right here
live and in person
are you guys feeling pretty confident
she's going down no no way she's going
down he's a big talker he is not going
down i'm going to bed
i'm not going down her back to texas
these are the kind of fights i'm into
because they're healthy and not scary
i'm in and we're going to find something
creative and i have to tell you we're
going to go to a quick commercial break
stick around because i want to see what
you guys did with this stuff so stick
around cause we're going to see what you
did when we come back all right
the incredibly talented designer mikael
welch and part of the drew crew and his
innovative challenger sustainable
stylist sarah tarasinski these pieces
are incredible i'm really excited to
hear from each of you about process so
that we can all learn and we're going to
start with macau okay so
my process honestly drew was pretty
pretty simple so
the basic thing here i had an ottoman
you can pick an old item it up at home
at a thrift store etc i found a big
oversized coat once i saw that it could
cover the piece i moved on to
accessories i found another coat that
had beautiful buttons and then i found a
cute little leather belt cut it in half
and use that as little strap handles
but i have one other little thing i want
to show you too so we got the
accessories done i want it just like an
extra element because you know how you
are you want things to be practical you
want them to be functional and that's
like really big with whatever i bring to
you it's true so check out me so well so
this was a coat i saved the little
pocket so that you can put your tv
remote
i'll tell you two reasons why i love
this um i can still tell that there's
coat elements yes because of the buttons
yes absolutely um i love the leather
strap certainly this tone of leather
against the black like herringbone yes
absolutely so there's a lot of things
working for me about this glad you like
it all right sarah now um i want to see
your before picture so we can see the
transition okay beautiful lamps yeah so
a huge thing for me when i thrift is i
like to look for things that i see a lot
you see a lot of lamps a lot of books a
lot of ties so i decided to gather them
together and create this fabulous little
book situation so the great thing about
lamps especially ones that are glass on
the bottom that are crystal is that
lamps screw apart you can screw the top
screw the bottom they come apart like an
accordion and then i just took battery
operated lights and inserted them in the
bottom up into the lantern itself they
come on and off and you can use wow you
can use a
little remote control battery operated
lights it's so simple to slide them back
up you you screw everything back on i
used some of the pieces that were left
over obviously i took the lamp bulb the
light bulb part screws right off and
then i went through and i painted the
bottom of this a little took a little
bit of tie i see that because that
little tail was not there before a
little accent the great thing about
these is that you can use them on your
table you can hang them somewhere and
then you just take your books and you
cover them old school with the ties like
we did with paper books right to give
your books a little jazz up and then
even i mean you got the remote control
but drew um how about when you want to
hide some stuff from your kids
you just make a little pocket
uh-huh you got the remote do i need to
walk around you
it is it is impressive i love the way
that you tied in the fabric because what
i noticed about these lamps was how
these crystal balls played into this
crystal ball right um so i thought they
were tied together in that element but
that was the one thing i was seeing
between the two the fabric really brings
the just the glue a fun little thing a
fun little situation both pieces are
really unique and i think i might need a
little help from the audience to pick a
winner because i love you guys so much
i'm just not up for the challenge of
ever
dissing anything that you guys do all
right everybody let's make some noise
for mikael if you're loving his style
okay
now let's make some noise if you prefer
sarah's creation
well
i mean
i'm just gonna go with you both when all
right i hear my crown
[Applause]
magic
miscellaneous materials oh magicians and
i want to thank you so much
mikael and sarah because
as much as i would love to take one of
you down i think that there is really
merit in both approaches they're very
different it's not an apples to apples
comparison there's something here for
everyone and i just love you guys and
showing us and teaching us what's
possible
thank you thank you
all right michelle sarah thank you so
much
[Music]
you